The jogan Experience well that's the
craziest thing about 1883 is that you
don't have to do any dramatic
embellishment there's doesn't have to be
any any [__] with the truth it's that
is literally what went down those people
literally came here they you were
telling me on the phone that what
percentage of the people that that made
the track across couldn't even speak
English you know it something like 40%
you know they used to come in from they
would come into and of course what what
our government was doing was we needed
people for a multitude of reasons uh
after the Civil War so many of the
workforce have been killed you know one
point something million soldiers died
that that we know of we don't know how
many other
civilians so we needed people um we
needed people to settle the West cuz
Manifest Destiny basically said hey you
know there's all this land we bought
from whoever we bought it from France I
guess the Louisiana Purchase um and we
can't settle it because every time we we
try the Lakota or the commanche kick the
[__] out of us so we should send a bunch
of central Europeans and Eastern
Europeans over there and let them get in
the middle of it and so in all of these
uh and you can you can look up if you
were to put it into the computer you can
pull up all these pamphlets they would
put out and ads they would put out in
newspapers in Romania and Norway
obviously Ireland did it everywhere
Germany and said come free land
yeah come get your free land and when I
started researching it um you know there
were people that would come from areas
where it was against the law to swim
they were not allowed to swim wow there
weren't no one knew how to swim it was
against the law to swim the law to
swim what the
f that seems so in what seems so insane
what what really struck me I mean I I
did a lot of thinking about that show
last night like it ended I did my binge
I ended the binge at like 2:00 in the
morning and you know at night time I do
some of my most [__] up thinking
because everyone is asleep in in my
house it's just me and I and I I
generally do most of my writing when
everyone's asleep and I was just
thinking that's 140 years ago that's
nothing I'm 56 years old when I was in
high school it was in 1983 so that was a
100 years ago I was a sophomore in high
school so I was
100 years is nothing 100 years before
that you make your way across the
country on a [__] wagon and you get
free land yeah a 100 years that's so
short a period of time it's so hard for
us to really appreciate how recent that
is and how how [__] insane the change
in this country over such a short period
of time has been meteoric meteoric
nothing like something in the last day
or two that and I'm going to get it
wrong
but
1937 is closer to
1984 than 2023 is to 84 something like
that yeah and if you think about the the
gap between 1984
2023 and then what 84 was like I was
alive you were alive to now it doesn't
seem like that dramatic a change
obviously there is internet but you
still had C you had phones you couldn't
take them with you but you had them but
1937 we haven't even we haven't even
made penicillin yet right that's just 40
years yeah trench warfare yeah yeah
World War I no these these they came
over here they didn't speak the language
they knew nothing about the land knew
nothing about the water had no it did by
the way you can be rest assured it did
not say in that advertisement in the
Romanian times there's other people who
already live there who will kill you
when you show up and didn't mention any
of that um they didn't hear about the
Indians till they got to Galviston and
you know they're buying their supplies
you need a gun what would he need a gun
well the Indians the who what are you
talking about who are Indians well
you're going to find out yeah that was a
part of uh Empire of the summer Moon you
know that these folks had just establish
these homesteads and had no idea and the
commanches would show up and just
slaughter them they had no idea they had
no idea that there was even a concern
and they had a figure fig out along the
way yeah and that you know and you read
in that book and and from a military
standpoint it's such a just an
impressive achievement that nikona
decided he was going to raid all the way
to Galveston and he marched through
burned Austin went all the way to
galvaston everybody got on their boats
went out on their boats and watched him
burn galvaston ex then they went in and
looted all the stores and found these
parasols you know you could sit there
and block the Sun and the Ki thought
that's the freaking smartest thing I
wish we'd had fabric to do that with so
all the Braves took these
parachutes and when they rode off
there's thousands of commanche warriors
with parasols of all these different
colors block getting the sun off their
shoulders running away with umbrellas
yeah that's insane but what a what a
terrifying visual that would be oh yeah
oh I mean I had no idea until I read
Empire the summer Moon and then I had
the author come in what is his name
again SG Gwen s is that
it great great [__] guy and he found
out when he moved to Texas like he he
moved here and then was researching
Texas history seen sewen and uh when he
moved here and he was researching Texas
then he was like oh my God like how how
do I not know about all this how do I
not know what this happened how do I
know not know about the Texas Rangers
and how they were established and why
they they needed them and what what went
down yeah it was the it was the Wild
West yeah well one of the reasons why
Texas is such a crazy place it's like
this was kind of The Last Stand yeah and
and Texas was its own Nation for you
know 14 years 13 years and it and it's
still you know that Independence is
still pretty embedded in it yeah they
want to put it back on the ballot every
year I mean it just decimated I think
Kera killed 60% of the kamanche yeah
they said that 90% of the people killed
in North America were killed by diseases
90% of the Native Americans yeah yeah
and that that story hasn't been told
properly you know and that's what I I
really appreciated about 1883 it's like
you you talked about I mean this was
like the end of the Native American
Empire essentially this was when there
was still a little bit of Buffalo left
there're still you know they're moving
Indians to reservations then the Indians
that were out they were resisting it you
know and it's just and then these people
are trying to make their way in this
[__] wagon train across the country
what what percentage of those people
died that were trying to do that I mean
I don't know that there's any anywhere
along the Oregon Trail you could you can
drive along or you know there's markers
just everywhere everywhere and
especially the further up you get into
Wyoming and the further you start
getting through like the Lander cut off
uh and South pass then they're just and
that's the ones that you know that got a
marker yeah so it's how do you know
right you know the hand cart uh the
Mormon Church brought a lot of people
out and they didn't have a lot of money
enough money to give them uh full wagons
even though that's what they' promised
so they made these Hand cards that
people would pull from wherever they
took off from somewhere in Ohio uh to
try and get to to Utah um and so these
people pulled them by hand they put
their wife and their gear their kids or
whatever and then they'd pull them these
two wheeled carts like chariots without
a horse and you know one winter they
left to late and got caught in the
winter and the whole trick was if you
didn't make it to the certain spot in
Wyoming by July 4th you were not going
to make it you were going to get caught
in the pass and you're going to die and
something like 25,000 people died in one
year just mind numbing statistics insane
yeah insane and it's it's so interesting
that the the early films on the west
they were they never covered that the
early films on the west were like these
really sort of shallow surface films
that were fun movies you know cowboys
versus Indians the Spaghetti Westerns
and that kind of stuff but no one had
any sort of real understanding of what
actually went down no you didn't the
notion of getting free land uh that you
could go farm uh with by the way nothing
you're going to go somewhere with
nothing like there's no stores you're
going to have to make everything you
have to figure it all out on on your own
who would choose that not a successful
blacksmith not somebody that's got a
nice comfortable home in Maryland or
wherever and why why why would you do
that you have to have no other option
right right all the people that came
over from from whatever European nation
they came from they didn't come for an
adventure right they came because they
were [__] starving my family came
over from Ireland because of the Potato
Famine they didn't they didn't want to
they had to right they were dying so
they had to come so that's why everyone
came desperation like desperation is
what settled the West fueled by a
manifest destiny which was which was a
cruel very cruel you know Insidious idea
that a bunch of politicians had that
says hey we can either send the Army out
there and just go to war and we've been
doing that and we've been getting the
[__] handed to us because the Lakota
were until the repeating rifle came
around the Lakota and the kamanche the
arapo even the sou mean we did not have
their skill level on a horse their their
arrows were actually more effective than
our single shot muskets like they were a
superior Army and and stayed that way it
wasn't until we started sacking Villages
when the Braves were gone when their
soldiers were gone we when that dirty
[__] started then it started turning the
tide and then when we killed the food
source that was the end of it yeah which
is part of the wiping out of the Buffalo
I mean it was a commodity for sure but
it was also there was a concerted effort
to cut off their food source it was but
it was also you know there was a demand
the Buffalo tongue was the number one
delicacy in New York City isn't that
crazy the tongue the tongue which nobody
wants anymore oh
no and then they sold all the they sold
all the the Buffalo skins to France and
they made giant massive silly robes well
at one point in time the richest man one
of the richest men in the world was he
dealt in beaver pelts yeah I don't doubt
it there was [__] Beaver everywhere
they wiped out most the beaver in this
country yeah you know but they've come
back yeah they've come back but not
nearly to where they were no but they've
come back it's pretty I mean it's pretty
impressive how much they've come back
and you know because you'll get what
they call the movie flu where you just
just get run down you just I mean the
hours are you know it's 14 16 hours a
day yeah and then and you have deadlines
and you have a budget and you have to do
it that way I mean the bud yeah we have
a budget but you've seen my shows they
they they they they let me run so I have
the CGI in 1883 I was like this is
insane because I don't want to give
anything away but there's a scene with a
storm where you're like oh my God like
you can do some wild [__] today well the
other thing is yes but the other thing
is I waited till the day was 60 mph
winds to shoot that oh perfect I let I
let God do a lot of the CGI nice they're
like there's a terrible storm coming in
and I said let's Swip the
schedule yeah because there's no way you
could ever have done that with their
hair and all the things flying around
yeah yeah it was it [__] great man
it's a great show how about that
ending it was rough it was rough like I
was just walking around my house like
two hours afterwards and the funny thing
is I told the audience what was going to
happen in the first scene yeah I know
that was a wild thing you did yeah
that's it's like you're waiting for it
throughout all the episodes you know
there's only 10 so you're like when how
does this go down it it did it
definitely added a layer of anticipation
it's brilliant man it really is it's one
of the best shows I've ever seen and I
shot 70% of it 80% of it at the 4 sixes
how the [__] is Tim McGraw and Faith
Hill so good that's crazy isn't it how
are they so good at acting did you well
let me tell you what every singer can
act just like every comedian can act um
dude he's [__] incredible did you
ever see him in uh in Friday Night
Lights the movie no that film that and I
know Pete ber came on uh the show with
you here Pete was a a big mentor of mine
um and and that to me is a perfect
Sports film it's if you haven't seen
that movie you got to see that movie
it's Billy Bob Thorton and Tim mcra
plays this abusive dad in it and it
is I mean he's raw but he is he's the
well runs deep with that
guy well you can tell in that movie man
or in your rather he you just 100% buy
that he is a stone cold killer yeah and
Faith she hadn't acted before we were
just hoping incredible and she brought
it incredible yeah but also it has to
help that they're real life married
couple you know there like there's like
real like you there's like layers of
chemistry when they're on the set
together and and the subtext and every
yeah it was and the heavy moments I
don't want to give anything away but
some of the heavy heavy moments between
the two of them you're like oh my God
imagine dealing with that the [__]
[__] those people had to deal with it's
Insanity it's heavy dude it's a heavy
show but it's really good and I think
it's a really important thing for people
to be aware of that that's a pretty act
it's obviously fiction but it's a pretty
accurate representation of how it went
down yeah I mean the circumstances are
imaginary but the tools and the things I
mean that's how they died and that's how
they
lived